nous avons indiqué depuis longtemps que
nous souhaitions conserver une cohérence
à notre liste et à notre programme
françois sauvadet a dit très clairement
on ne change pas de ligne on change pas
de programme on ne change pas l'équipe
on va voir on va se réunir demain matin
on va voir tout ça à tête reposée avec
l'ensemble des résultats affinés et
définitif dont nous disposerons ce n'est
pas encore le cas mais encore seule
instance pour debout la france moi je
connais bien maxime pied bon oeil et en
saône et loire
je sais très bien que les gens qui
votent debout la france et s'ils avaient
voulu voter un petit peu plus décalé il
serait déjà allé au front national au
premier tour donc je ne crois pas que ce
soit des gens qui ont vocation à aller
au front national
quand bien même sur certains thèmes on
pourrait penser
optiquement qu'il ya déjà des
rapprochements moi je pense que c'est
des gens qui restent dans des familles
républicaines et qui sont attachés à ce
socle commun et qui sont sur un vote
régional attachés à des idées
programmatique et je ne vois pas de
différence fondamentale avec maxime
thibeault sur ce qui est la gestion
d'une région mais c'est quand même ce
qui va importer aussi entre les deux
tours sur l'europe sur l'europe bien
évidemment il met la gérance de taille
il enfin l'europe la région savez la
région va gérer les fonds européens ça
c'est une chose mais ça demande pas un
précieux relais sa demande pas un
positionnement souverainistes ou pas
souverainiste les fonds européens ils
sont attribués aux régions quoi qu'il
advienne quel que soit votre coloration
politique qu'une le front national à
faire avec la gestion des fonds
européens